Some of your favorite TV shows have some of
the greatest Easter eggs in them, ranging
from opening credits to hidden movie references.
Show runners are creative individuals that
have a love for television and film, they
work very hard to hide these Easter eggs but
we do our best to find them for you.
Whether you like sitcoms, dramas, superhero
or another type of shoe, we have you covered
in this video from Screen Rant.
Let us know when we talk about one of your
favorite shows by liking this video and don’t
forget to subscribe and join the notification
squad for awesome videos like this one every
day.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Easter
Eggs That Take Popular TV Shows to Another
Level.
Community
Dan Harmon was the show runner for Community
for the first three seasons but his perfectionism
and last minute script updates were not loved
by the network, maybe this had to do with
the lack of stellar ratings.
So when production of season four started,
Harmon was out but in an unheard of move by
networks they brought him back in for season
five.
In season five, at the end of the opening
credits there is a pencil tapped up to reference
Harmon trying to fix his beloved show.
In former seasons there was no tape.
And episode from Season 3 and season 5
The Walking Dead
When fan-favorite Daryl digs through his bag
of meds to help T-Dog out, there is a familiar
blue looking drug on the bottom of the bag.
Remember that blue meth from the TV show,
Breaking Bad?
It looks like Daryl made a stop at Walter
White’s trailer before the apocalypse broke
out just in case someone needed…um, pain
meds.
All we know is the blue product looks very
familiar and both shows were produced by AMC.
An interesting hidden Easter egg from the
TV crew.
Season 1, Episode 2
Friday Night Lights
Some people might forget that TV show Friday
Night Lights is not only a show starring Minka
Kelly but also the football team she roots
for, the Dillon Panthers.
The football players have a “P” decal
on their helmets but realistically they would
have “D”, as that would stand for Dillon
High School.
But the show runner Peter Berg wanted to play
homage to his feature film of the same name,
so "P" is actually a reference to the Permian
Panthers.
Did we mention Minka Kelly is in this show?
Daredevil
The law office of Nelson & Murdock on Daredevil
pledges itself to defending those that wouldn't
be able to defend themselves, even if that
means only being paid in the form of food.
When Foggy receives a pie from a happy client
he replies, “Strawberry, rhubarb... you
will be mine..."
This is in reference to the movie Wayne’s
World when Wayne speaks of his desired guitar.
The writers are fans of the SNL sketch and
wanted to show a little love to Mike Myers.
Yeah baby!
Season 2, Episode 1
The Simpsons
Undeniable The Simpsons is one of the most
creative shows to ever air on television and
there is no way to know all the references
the writers and animators make.
The opening credits are famous due to the
shows Couch Gag, but there is another reference
in those credits.
When the show first aired we see Maggie mistakenly
put through the scanner of a supermarket till
with a hidden Easter egg.
Originally, the price came up as $847.63 referencing
the average monthly cost of raising a child
in America in 1989.
That is just one of thousands of other references
The Simpsons have put in their long running
show.
Season 1 Epsiode
Doctor Who
Starting over 50 years ago, Doctor Who has
garnered fans from all over the world.
The British science-fiction TV show depicts
the adventures of a Time Lord called "The
Doctor", an extraterrestrial being from the
planet Gallifrey.
In early years of the show, the Doctor carried
around an umbrella quite often so when Clara
goes into a room full of old props, like the
Doctor’s cot, she briefly picks up an umbrella
with a bamboo handle.
Even though the Doctor’s umbrellas were
mostly remembered as being fancier in the
earliest of the shows episodes they looked
just like this one.
Bravo Moffat and prop department!
Season 7, Journey To The Centre Of The Tardis
Supergirl
Lena Luthor is the half-sister of the infamous
Lex Luther and is now the CEO of L-Corp in
the television show Supergirl.
In season two before boarding a helicopter
she admits to not enjoying flying, even admits
that “statistically speaking, it’s the
safest way to travel.”
This is a nod to what Superman first says
to Lois Lane when they meet for the first
time in Superman.
It’s a great way to tip your hat to Christopher
Reeves.
Season 2, Episode 1
Friends
One of Lisa Kudrow’s big breaks came from
the NBC sitcom Mad About You, she played a
less pleasant twin sister Ursula to Kudrow’s
Phoebe Buffay in Friends.
When Helen Hunt and Leila Kenzie make cameo
appearances in Friends, the stumble across
Phoebe.
They mistake Phoebe for Ursula and Phoebe
doesn’t know what to make of it.
Not surprisingly she’s confused.
A pretty cool cross over from two great sitcoms
with the great Lisa Kudrow.
The One With Two Parts, Part 1
Sherlock
The elder brother to Sherlock Holmes, Mycroft
quotes the work of Oscar Wilde in the season
4 episode entitled The Final Problem.
The quote is from Wilde’s The Importance
of Being Earnest and it’s when he says,
"truth is rarely pure and never simple."
This is a nod to Wilde who inspired Arthur
Conan Doyle to write his second novel about
the famed detective, The Sign of the Four.
Interestingly the encounter between the two
writers also convince Wilde to write The Picture
of Dorian.
Talk about inspiration.
Season 4, The Final Problem
Stranger Things
Eleven, the Eggo eating character from the
hit TV series Stranger Things has a lot of
resemblances to Spielberg’s ET character.
She’s a weird outsider, who is alone on
a planet and helps the main character mature.
But the creators of the show say she’s based
off the anima character Elfen Lied, both are
psychic, young girls being experimented on
by a secret agency.
These organizations are both run by a father
figure to the little girls and on their breakout
scenes they kill guards.
On top of all that they are both given numbers
as names, not to mention Elfen sounds a lot
like Eleven.
There you have it ten Easter Eggs That Take
Popular TV Shows to Another Level.
Don’t forget to subscribe to Screen Rant
for more fun videos.
Thanks for watching.